no
ok esploso
eccolo o no il rituale sta per iniziare
che rituale di solito gli spazi il
pagliaccio cattivo è tornato se lo avete
visto la bisogno di precedente qui siamo
andati alla festa di compleanno di farci
mai finita molto male andate a vederlo
qualora questa è la sua bellezza è
tornato e vuole vendicarsi su di noi
como di pre di pop corn e iniziamo
questa vettura sarà così come finora
sembra tutto tranquillo sereno e allegro
come quando siamo andati alla sua festa
di compleanno però poi è successo
qualcosa di molto ma non ho mai deciso
cosi come e dove vogliamo andare ho
sentito qui che il pat fry
dove stiamo assieme questa volta stiamo
in un treno in un bus in una m e qui
siamo seduti uno di fronte all'altro che
sapeva spetterà questa volta cosa avrà
organizzato baci questa volta cerchiamo
di non farci fregare con i suoi giorno
che ti eccoci qua siamo in un centro
commerciale
siamo da soli non centro commerciale
sono così felice che siamo di nuovo
assieme
lo so che è passato un po di tempo da
dalla festa di compleanno e si è stato
un po strano sicuramente ancora non ci
posso credere a quello che ci è successo
neanche io però non perdiamo tempo a
parlarne ok non perdiamo tempo a parlare
di pace allora dobbiamo esplorare il
centro commerciale
che bello se qualcuno non ti emozioni
allora meno ma siamo nel water di
cappelli non si farà a pezzi
per questo non parla qualcosa mi dice
che tra poco dovremmo iniziare a
scappare velocissimo e belle ma non mi
posso prendere qualcosa da qui un
cappello una maniera non parla sembrano
abbiamo utilizzati abbiamo aiutato gli
altri negozi allora io esplorò il piano
di sopra vitale tra cercando un negozio
di oliva sicura esatto ma qui ci sono
solo borse scarpe e vado anch'io al
piano di sopra tramite questo negozio e
tu per carino in questo centro
commerciale azzurro poterlo esplorare
ogni mese di animali che bella come
storie dei gatti di cagliari riviverne
mm colmarla gli assetati ragazzi si va
volete un caffè si sono unite a andiamo
al caffè qua vicino ok tra le vuole bere
un caffè dovevo scendere al piano di so
se è una freccia che indica dove andare
se
devo sbrigarmi se saltiamo
buonissimo profumo andiamo abbiamo davo
16 nella caffetteria dove la capite
riina
vogliamo la freccia dove stava bisogna
scritto caffè dove dobbiamo andare
quando arriverà a baci con siamo nella
caffetteria con questo punto è
fantastico il rilassante se non avete
sentito della nuova notizia ma la
notizia no non sentiamo molte notizie in
questi giorni stanno costruendo un nuovo
c'è un nuovo parco giochi parco giochi
nel
magazine benedetto commerciale ha detto
parco giochi ti ho detto parco giochi
dietro che è successo e perché le luci
hanno fatto così
queste luci devono per forza fare così
ma chi non prova grazie vie sono quelli
che stanno costruendo il parco giochi
hanno dei problemi con l'elettricità ma
questo è più dell'elettricità quel caso
mi dice che sta arrivando e ditemi che
anche voi l'avete sentito certo l'ho
sentito che cos'era sono scomparsi tutti
dove sono andati guarda e buio fuori
dopo un tempo siamo stati da quanto
tempo siamo qua dentro proposta
comune di briga 10 da qua ok no la porta
è chiusa lo sapevo ma ci proviamo dalla
porta in questione entrate e quale tipo
di far parte stesso problema negative
sta andando avanti vedremo quando c'è
scritto uscita qui forse siamo servi sì
c'è mancato poco molto poco anche come
giorno bloccata dovuta anche l'ultima
porta sicuramente si usa però
si stanno accendendo delle luci verdi ei
che cosa sta succedendo
chi è
[Musica]
non lo so ma andiamo a vedere di che si
tratta
ok
temendo
cosa nascondiamoci dentro dove stanno
facendo i lavori dove e come fatto da
rivali
ma stanno cantando che che strane ma chi
sono o no ci sono anche altri
no che sto pregando questo protetto
mica te sto scappando
non mi scontravo non mi esce pare
insultato
grazia come difficile dell'altro e dati
cuore fuori un altro vita
che che cos'erano quelli non grata
perché ci stavano inseguendo
non so ma dobbiamo sbrigarci dobbiamo
più continua a dragare abbinare trova
una via
che anzi non è riuscita c'è scritto lui
e qua stai lontano non sembra che stanno
costruendo un altro intoppo giochi e in
effetti sembra qualcos'altro
tento vendiamo ora
c'è una porta sopra
altra roba
piscina ok propria vita qua sbrigati
dobbiamo salire da soprattutto a scala
sbrigati aspetta su caduto tra i primati
arrivi che è successo ti sei sfracellata
non ti face prince non ocse sono vivo
non ci credo di nuovo ok sono quanto è
tanta su quello arancione bravo adesso
prende la rincorsa è stata perché non
devi andare su quei fumi verdi
stavi suo
credo che dobbiamo premere questo
bottone sembra che l'aborto sia
controllata da qualche altra parte
dobbiamo trovare un pulsante per aprirla
penso che dovremmo dare la scala quale
sky ecco la dobbiamo prendere qualcosa
per
atleta ancora a prendere la qana ma
dobbiamo trovare qualcosa per far
abbassare la scala ecco che cosa ha dato
bottone un palo
by corri ridiamo si superò pinzette
questa mattina anche se un po di ansia
pronti ma andiamo perché non hai paura
delle antenne io ho paura delle critiche
che abbiamo altri attento a non cadere
eh sì chiaro siamo da qua
no si va avanti
io penso che dobbiamo saltare su queste
qui bianche xi stai molto attento ok ce
l'ho fatta non ci credo ah ecco il
pulsante forza di prova a premere
ok ora la porta dovrebbe essere aperta
ma qui noi dobbiamo tornare
povero vitale non ripete la chiamata
che è successo che visto cadere è rotta
la
cosa stai attento mi riguardo alla borsa
sia aperta per fortuna ecco ti mandiamo
erano avete lasciato mi piace mi
lasciano e soci perché se questo video
raggiunge il 7 mila mi piace faremo un
altre schifezze tipacci ho una
sensazione strana mi sembra qualcosa di
familiare
non pensi che questa sia un posto di
paci vero non può essere è morto o se
n'è andato via per sempre ma nessuno ha
mai trovato il corpo dopo l'esplosione
vero perché sia stata lei stessa lo so
ma dobbiamo credere che lui che come qui
che sta bene vedi ci sono delle
scintille che stanno uscendo fuori da
cui bene questa donna questa porta
funziona e dobbiamo trovare qualcosa di
elettrico per farla funzionare allora
dobbiamo trovare un fusibile per la
porta forse negli armadietti dobbiamo
vedere cosa
eccolo dove hanno trovato la vedo
e ancora per fortuna non è arrivato
pazzi bene dovrebbe essere morto
nell'esplosione
ricordate la scarsità di prum ma il
mister così la porta si è aperta perché
veniamo sempre posti così belli
non ne ho idea
ma continuiamo ad andare ok
andiamo negativo paure che oggi punterà
fuori all'improvviso giochiamo e ip
stati un labirinto
giusto in tempo c'è mancato davvero poco
e se questo pulsante rigate delle
palline sembra proprio non sapevamo
salire solazzi che ansia con questa
musica vuoi
e alla fine del video scriveteci se vi è
piaciuta più questo è che promuove o
l'altro a che prolunga di paci anche noi
vi diremo quale sia piaciuta di più ma
sembra che per cui non possiamo uscire
non lo è bloccato ok troviamo un'altra
strada che dobbiamo continuare ad andare
avanti questione porta ma è chiusa
delle luci
proviamo ad andare di qua allora o non
abbiamo altra porta chiusa
beh dovevamo aspettarcelo adesso che
cosa succederà penso che dobbiamo
attivare queste tre luci per aprire la
porta ok sembra una buona idea allora
dobbiamo aprire le tre valvole per
attivare la porta previste non lista una
qui
ma dovrebbe essere questa una lo
attivata io creavo ecco di un'altra
ok è vero la due sono attiva mi manca
una
per restare da sola eccola l'ho trovata
vita viene da questa parte aiuto nell
aiuto termine solo no allora ancora
system ricordi di nuovo
non riesco a capire dobbiamo scappare da
questo mondo se poi devo andare
vieni qua persone uscita dove abbiamo
aperto la porta corri da veterinari
state rimandate cota eletto che la porta
si è aperta
andiamo
c'è mancato poco non riesco a vedere
niente dove siamo non è un'idea
penso che possiamo solo andare avanti e
di tipo punto di domanda
sappiamo che cosa dobbiamo fare penso
che questo sia un altro gioco di pazzi
allora si stanno accendendo le luci man
mano che andiamo avanti
per questa mi disse che spunterà
ok cosa era quello fatto queste cose
paurose c'è una porta
o no paci spunterà da lì qualcosa mi
dice che spunterà dall istituto natali
pertanto ma stati portati ad un vado non
possiamo spostarci molto
[Musica]
ok riesploso bacon o no ecopass disse
lui mi ha detto io sono mancato no paci
ma sembra di vero però e colori diversi
com'è possibile che sia ancora vivo
abbiamo visto l'esplosione non sono
molto intelligenti vero vi siete
dimenticati che io posso fare questo
comparire a
marzo qui
adesso dobbiamo capire adesso quindi non
sei mai stato nell esplosione ecco
perché non hanno mai trovato
non ti hanno mai trovato basta parlare è
tempo di finirla adesso
sono caduto sotto so caduto sotto ma
sono pro vivo
ci sei tu
non posso crederci che siamo l'aveva chi
stesse ci stava guardando tutto questo
tempo dobbiamo fermarlo una volta per
tutte si
sia questo il ponte giurino
attenta non è stabile
l'unica cosa instabile qui sono le
vostre menti r dove sono i pazzi
vieni a combattere con noi aiuto la
cifra serve eccolo dove mi guardava e
questo sarà meglio se stava zitto
ne sono altri martelli prova a passare
attraverso la parte danneggiata del
ponte vuoi andare più veloce
pochi ce l'ho fatta
stai attento o ce l'hai fatta si sono
quindi attualità tutte le skype room che
abbiamo fatto sono servite d'allenamento
però meglio se nei mercati c'e nessun
può sempre andare dopo quello che hai
fatto questo è quello che ti meriti una
bomba sono bastati sono stati ok
escludere il ponte presto salta siamo in
questa parte del ponte o che non creano
già stati e adesso
eccolo ricomparso l'i
gli ho detto di lasciar perdere
non riuscirete mai a scappare da me
siete miei aiuto ammesso dalle fiamme
salta quando basta il fuoco tra alta ok
grazie a foto 1 sotto
o attentato bisogna spostarsi ogni volta
aiuto
smettono di loro vietato
età
batta la faccio più
sta diventando sempre più difficile se
ne avremmo fatto adesso i tuoi giochetti
non ci possono fermare pace sei tu che
devi lasciar perdere smettetela
se mi avesse silvi foste uniti a me
niente di questo sarebbe successo
non ci credo e nemici non abbondano sono
caduto dall'altra parte del ponte ha
tutto daccapo adesso no
sbrigati se n'è andato
non lo so potrebbe essere ancora qui
dopo che forte sembra una sorta di
tempio dai arrivando penso di sì non lo
so
mentre dice niente hanno da sempre ma
non solo dai dati purtroppo un vitale è
stato sfracellato quindi devo aspettare
che ritorni mai fregati guarda ci sono
delle statue di falli
qualcosa mi dice che non sarà facile
contro questo tempo più vediamo ok siamo
entrati wow la testa di paci
ciao c'è nessuno qui venuti i simboli
potreste finirla di
prenderci in giro
non sappiamo perché siamo qui ma andrò
torta tardi sappiamo già che siete
aspetta un minuto ma che cosa quindi con
abbiamo
sono molto maleducato non avervi
presentato le altre persone a cipolla a
diverse personalità lui no e vero gli
altri capi vive di o
dite ciao alle mie seguaci saremo là ci
hai davvero dei seguaci
sì dopo quello che è successo l'ultima
volta sono ancora più popolare
questo è fuori di testa
basta ne ho avuto abbastanza delle
vostre domande e guardi e prendetevi
[Musica]
dove dobbiamo scappare io sono saltato
dentro l'amministrazione
bene non ci credo non la mia testa così
se c'è siamo stati catturati e buttati
in questa prigione prigione
stai scherzando ci sono anche delle
guardie
come facciamo di uscire ma si ha detto
che aveva bisogno di un sacrificio vuole
sacrificare noi o no pure
il timer dal dott non penso che riescono
a parlare è vero
non lasciate che gli altri si sentano
questo qui può parlare così ci sta
parlando
state indietro state dietro le sbarre
si sta facendo uscire
ci credo sei sicuro non è che adesso ci
vuole picchiare con martello sì perché
ci sta aiutando
non c'è tempo da spiegare devo andare
[Musica]
il rituale sta per iniziare e devo
essere lì buona fortuna
c quindi dobbiamo tacere
wow
dobbiamo passare attraverso la guardia
senza essere notati attento
trovano strada per uscire ok proviamo di
qua accetta tentate touch è una cosa
rossa qui questa dovrebbe essere
all'uscita quale questa
seguimi ok
dobbiamo trovare una leva per aprire la
portata è troppo attenta
dentro non devi portare nelle nostre
altrimenti ti vedono una leva per uscire
ecco la brava ora riportami dovere
dov'era la premuta stilo premuta andiamo
è trovato più andare a dovere la porta
dobbiamo scappare attraverso la porta
tenta cielo guardia nasconditi
via
allora dov'era quale non mi ricordo
la verità dove era la porta d'uscita
forse di qua no non povero queste erano
le celle no qua non c'è niente da tempo
c'è mancato poco meno di quanto dove
l'uscita è un labirinto
per un po con noi ha fatto
solo
scappando no che anche a 3000 spero non
abbia dato l'allarme forse qui c'è una
porta guarda ho trovato lo porto per
salire sul trovo
[Musica]
seguendo
no devi scappare devi scappare ecco che
forse qui
brigate
hanno preso la strada sbagliata
non mi sento la mia città unita
ai lanci pazzi
[Musica]
qui ci sono due statue di pace gigante
guarda questo posto e il cristallo più
grande che abbia mai visto cosa
ci sono alcuni dei lavoratori è
collegabile sono i lavoratori del
negozio dobbiamo liberarli come facciamo
ma non è che poi si sbroglierà ma come
la 3t
pronti a unirvi a voi se sia giusto in
tempo per il quale sta per iniziare che
rituale dobbiamo
sì qua ci sono delle mattonelle da
spostare ma non so come si fa faremo
ogni moto nelle
non ho mai lavorato riguarda si fa come
si parlò è spostato questore non capisco
varini dobbiamo spostare questo come
stato interrompere il rituale non
possiamo lasciar tifare questo di
qualsiasi cosa si tratta ma ho capito
forse ok cosa dobbiamo dobbiamo scendere
giù si deve fare così spostare questi
quindi vediamo lì sta entrando nella
nato questo attenta uno deve baciare
questo che mi pare quindi meglio che io
ho capito ciò bravo che no no no ti devi
spostare
portati
no aspetta ora combatte come dovrebbe
essere giusto adesso dobbiamo vedere se
ce n'è un altro che sta succedendo
miste era la sua alleata nelle altre si
provi di ricorsi e vero la signora della
del nella sala giochi di quello che ci
ha tradito la reception
receptionist
la mia extra assistente leale questa
cosa succede a quelli che mi tradiscono
le vuole fare la sta mettendo nella lava
anche lei che sta succedendo perché la
si è fermata non guardare noi non
abbiamo fatto niente di male
la stanza a sfornare o no è stata
realizzata dov'è andata
[Musica]
dove non la vedo o baci ti sei
dimenticato che io posso fare dei
trucchetti come te
vediamo come fai a risparmiare energia
è
ricaduto è successo che fa sono andato
sul mercato che sta succedendo è
successo che avevo messo fuoco a due
pilastri e c'è un sacco di poter del
cristallo che sta uscendo
[Musica]
succedendo questo cristallo orologio del
cervello a tutti quanti e tutti quanti
mi aiuteranno qui siamo nel mondo era il
mondo è qualcosa di serve quel cristiano
è
arrivato non non posso fartelo fare
pezzi e proprio tardi sta per succedere
[Musica]
o no abbiamo fallito
tradizione
da tutte le persone stanno scappando e
c'è un raggio di luce verde che esce
dall'edificio
brainwash lending però abbiamo preso il
peggio
ha fatto il lavaggio del cervello
anche questa volta abbiamo avuto il
finale
peggiore se non troviamo l'escape room
nel canale di vitale magari proprio una
beacher questa volta lasciate un bel mi
piace secondo me era bellissimo ero
molto
presente sembra un film
anche in altre era molto bella epoque
sarà più lunga e si sente preferisco
questo va bene è una più bella la prima
o la seconda non l'avete vista cliccate
in una di queste castelli e per vederle
era villa savo 4 katelinas criticare blu
delle nostre altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite buona visione